this is about death our death and how
useful it might be to dwell on the
prospect rather more than we're inclined
to many things that we need to tackle a
left aside because we're scared we're
scared to fail scared to be alone with
our own feelings scared to eject certain
people from our lives scared to tell our
partners who we really are scared to
take our dreams seriously from fear we
delay the lives we know we should be
leading there is a dark but useful
solution to this delay it doesn't
involve reassurance or reminding
ourselves that there is time it involves
aligning our thoughts to something
radically larger and scarier than any of
our doubts and hesitations something
that can jolt us from our timid lethargy
we should use the thought of death not
to make us despair of life but to shake
us into more committed ly pursuing the
life we know we need to lead we will act
when the fear of death is finally
allowed to trump the fear of failure or
humiliation compromise or shame we need
with the best of intentions to nurture
fear imagine you're 34 and will live
optimistically to be 90 this is how many
winters you have left frighten yourself
at every turn consider how often cancer
and heart disease
strike far ahead of the average death
age read of the violent random ways of
strokes and aneurysms talk to people at
55 and let them explain to you how
swiftly their years went terrify
yourself not in the name of despair but
of impatient courageous authenticity in
the olden days people would buy a skull
and place it on their desk to keep their
thoughts focused it can now be awkward
buying a skull let this be a skull fear
is the big obstacle to doing the
important stuff deliberately scare
yourself about the only thing you need
to fear
and thereby be liberated to get on with
everything else that so badly needs
doing
you